[Musique]
messieurs bonjour nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne Youtube qui
s'appelle ser viiew on aurait voulu
avoir vos points de vue respectifs sur
l'actualité numérique sur la loi
renseignement sur des questions de
terrorisme de géopolitique on va donner
la parole à Jean-Marc Manac Jean-Marc
Manac qui êtes-vous
ou
euh je suis journaliste je suis devenu
journaliste par hasard journalise
investigation par hasard sur internet
par hasard et j'ai trouvé ça vachement
bien en fait de creuser euh j'ai trouvé
plein plein plein plein plein plein
plein de truc et euh et voilà je suis
journaliste indépendant aujourd'hui je
suis plus rattaché à une rédaction
particulière vous collaborez avec quel
type de média et vous avez collaboré
avec quel type de médiia je de plus en
plus de télé là cette année je
travaillais pour France 4 avec vice et
pour une émission qui s'appelle l'autre
JT mais qui s'arrête parce que France 4
dev une chaîne familiale
euh je pige régulièrement au Canar
enchaîné j'ai travaillé à r sur image
j'ai longtemps travailler pour OVNI euh
fait pas mal de data journalisme et euh
et je pige de temps en
temps et j'ai pas mal bossé avec
Wikileak Mar rise qui êtes-vous euh euh
bah déjà pas pas Marc rise mais Marc res
pardon euh tombé dans le journalisme par
accident aussi après quelques années
passer sur les les bans de la fac de
droit deex euh voilà je je tapote
derrière mon écran depuis 97 ou 98 et je
me passionne pour tout ce qui est
régulation réglementation législation
et voilà je travaille pour next impact
où je suis rédacteur en chef qui est mon
seul et unique employ
et nous avons Yassir
oui Yassir comme Yassir est à cœur je
vais le laisser se présenter al cur
c'est un c'est c'est un grand mot je
l'utilise toujours avec des guillumets
je suis un
bidouilleur alors moi aussi il y a
beaucoup de hasard dans mon parcours
j'ai j'ai découvert le hacking il y a
très longtemps parce que j'avais créé un
site web qui n'avait aucun intérêt mais
alors aucun et il s'est fait hacker et
je me suis posé plein de questions à ce
moment-là comment pourquoi est-ce qu'il
y a des G sur Internet qui voudrait
haquer un site qui n'a aucun TER donc
c'est comme ça que je suis tombé dedans
puis après de fil en aiguille j'ai
travaillé dans des boîtes de conseils et
puis j'ai monté une petite boîte qui
fait de la sécurité et dernièrement une
plateforme qui met en relation les
hackurs et les entreprises pour
travailler ensemble et en parallèle je
suis tombé par hasard aussi dans mon
parcours dans ce qu'on appelle le média
citoyen où j'ai travaillé avec un
collectif qui s'appelait MF Kinch on
couvrait l'actualité du monde arabe et
ce qui se passait dans cette zone là je
vais redonner la parole à Jean-Marc
Manac Jean-Marc Manac on est au 21e
siècle comment ça se passe sur Internet
au niveau de la surveillance au niveau
du terrorisme estce que la les les
attitudes de nos gouvernements
respectifs ont ont quelques résultats
sur internet concernant la guerre contre
le terrorisme ben visiblement non vu
qu'il eu des attentats
euh comment ça se passe ça se passe
queon est encore majoritairement
gouverné par des gens que ce soit du
côté de
l'exécutif ou du côté des Parlement qui
ne comprennent pas ce dont il est
question à la fois les questions
relatives à Internet et les questions
relatives au renseignement donc on est
on est gouverné par des par des aveugles
en un sens ou en tout cas des malvoyants
plutôt est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est
pas un point de vue de journaliste ça
c'est un point de vue quelqu'un qui suit
ces questions depuis un certain nombre
d'années et et et au niveau du
renseignement si on voit que c'est pas
bon pourquoi il change pas parce queils
ont pas la
capacité de s'intéresser ou de se
remettre en question à votre avis ça ça
vient d' parce que c'est pyramidal c'est
c'est c'est vertical il faut bien
comprendre que on commence enfin des
gouvernements commencent par créer des
services de renseignement de façon
clandestine qui n'existe pas
officiellement ensuite on découvre leur
existence ensuite les parlementaires et
l'exécutif décident de créer une loi
pour encadrer juridiquement les
pratiques de ces services de
renseignement ensuite et là c'est ce
qu'on a vu que la loi renseignement la
technologie évolue enfin est- ce qu'il
faut on va revenir 91 la France est
condamnée par la CEDH pour des écoutes
téléphoniques CEDH vous pouvez dé Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et donc
il vote une loi qui encadre les écoutes
téléphoniques jusqu'en 91 les écoutes
téléphoniques n'existaient pas
officiellement il y a pas de cadre
juridique mais bien sûr qu'elles
existaient depuis au moins 45 vu que les
les premières tables d'écoute euh de la
police nationale en fait c'était les
tables d'écoute qu'ils avaient récupéré
de la guestapo pendant la guerre 3945
donc de 45 à 91 les policiers les
services de renseignement écoutaient en
parfaite illégalité à partir de 91 il y
a c'est donc encadré par la loi avec un
article 20 qui inclu la surveillance du
spectre herdien de de la loi ce qui
permet au services de renseignement
notamment extérieur la DGSE de pouvoir
écouter les
satellites se pose la question
d'utiliser cet article 20 pour écouter
les téléphones portables et là il y a la
Commission nationale de contrôle des
interceptions de sécurité la CNCIS qui
est la commission chargée de valider les
techniques de renseignement qui explique
au service de renseignement vous ne
pouvez pas utiliser l'article 20 pour
espionner les téléphones portables les
téléphones portables c'est comme les
lignes fixes vous devez d'abord nous
demander l'autorisation
et ensuite on vous l'accorde ou pas il
faut savoir que ces dernières années
grosso modo c'est un peu plus de 6000
cibles par an qui sont écouté par les
service de renseignement 6000 cibles
vous parlez du du premier échelon des
coûes ou 6000 cibles avec cible directe
direct et les cibles indirectes fait
combien je précise une cible ça peut
être une personne qui a carte ou 5 ou 10
cartes SIM ou ça peut être un groupe de
de TR qu personnes donc ça c'est les
écoutes directs qui sont faites par le
groupement interministal de contrôle le
GIC à côté de l'école militaire et ils
ont un quota qui a été élevé là depuis
les attentats de janvier ils peuvent pas
écouter plus de 2800 cibles en simultané
voilà ça c'est pour les écoutes directes
après il y a les systèmes de
surveillance
euh à l'étranger notamment et les ce
qu'on appelle la surveillance
internationale donc ça c'est une des
techniques de renseignement qui a été
légalisé par la loi renseignement
l'année dernière ce qui s'est passé
c'est que en 2008 Nicolas Sarkozi a pas
signé un un livre blanc sur la défense
donc qui donnait euh la voix suivre au
ministère de la Défense dans les années
à venir et il a été décidé de surveiller
internet donc pour surveiller internet
ils ont déployé ça aurait coûté 700 à 8
800 millions de d'euros ils ont déployé
des systèmes de collecte de masse au
niveau des câbles sous-marins pour
arriver à surveiller ce qui rentre et ce
qui sort à l'international mais ils ont
fait de même que la CNCIS avait dans les
années 90 ce qu'ils appellent la
jurisprudence créative une jurisprudence
créative de la CNCIS c'est quelque chose
qui fait jurisprudence mais qui n'est
pas publié au Journal officiel c'est
comme ça que ça s'appelle c'est pas un
terme légal mais c'est un terme consacré
ça a l'air très clair Marc que précise
juste ce truccl sur la jurisprudence
créative ils ont de même qu'ils ont
exclu la surveillance des téléphones
portabl au motif de l'article 20 ils ont
accepté qu' une surveillance de
l'Internet à l'international mais les
identifiant français devait être écrasé
on doit on ne peut pas utiliser ces
systèmes de collecte de masse de
surveillance internationale pour
surveiller des Français et ça c'est qui
a été consacré dans la loi dans la loi
renseignement l'année dernière pourquoi
pourquoi parce que c'est CIS qui
maintenant s'appelle CNCT Commission
nationale de contrôle des techniques de
renseignement estime que pour surveiller
un Français les services de
renseignement doivent d'abord demander
l'autorisation à la CNCT enfin
auparavant à la CNCIS maintenant la
cncttr par contre s'il s'agit de
surveiller un Marocain un Américain un
russe sur le territoire français sur le
territoire français alors sur le
territoire français c'est un petit peu
compliqué à l'étranger il doit la DGSE
doit demander l'autorisation de
surveiller un pays tout ce qui va ou qui
vient de la Syrie tout ce qui va ou qui
vient de l'État islamique tout ce qui
att trait à
Al-Qaïda après pour ce qui est de
surveiller Barack Obama que ce soit sur
le territoire national ou surveiller
Barack Obama à l'étranger il y a pas de
cadre légal qui fait queils doivent
demander l'autorisation à la CNCI un
étranger sur le territoire français
est-ce qu'il y a besoin de passer par
tout
ça après il y a tout ce qu'on il y a les
IMS Catchers qui sont donc des des
valises enfin qui se présent souvent
sous forme de valise mais qui peuvent
être camouflé dans les camionnettes et
qui permettent d'identifier qui est qui
usurpe en fait une antenne de téléphonie
mobile c'est ça c'est un peu voilà ce
qu'on attaque l'attaque de l'homme du
milieu m in the middle qui permet
d'usurper une bande téléphonique et donc
d'arriver à identifier tous les numéros
Imzi pour ça que s'appelle Imzi catcher
qui sont dans un périmètre voire diton
pour des des imicatures plus évolué
d'arriver à écouter des téléphones à la
volée Marc qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
ben pour un exécutif aveugle et sourd je
trouve qu'ils ont quand même pas mal de
d'appareillage auditif et et et d'aide à
la visualisation sur les les échanges
alors quelques précisions euh dès lors
qu'on évoque la question de la la
surveillance euh soit nationale soit
internationale se pose une question
limpide toute simple et bête et méchante
à partir de quand une communication
nationale ou internationale
euh pour faire simple la loi sur la
surveance des communication des
communications internationale qui a été
adopté après euh la loi sur le
renseignement euh qualifie comme tel
qualifie d'international une
communication dont au moins un des
identifiants de l'émetteur du récepteur
est situé à l'étranger voilà donc on
parle pas de nationalité de la notion de
français ou pas français ça pas
d'importance du tout puisque on na pas
des adresses IP colorisé en en bleu
blanc rouge sur les écrans et le le
spectre de de la loi est est très
intelligemment fait dans la mesure où si
on qualifie comme tel une communication
dont au moins une adresse IP est
géolocalisée à l'étranger euh cela peut
vouloir dire mais sans doute par
accident hein
que Monsieur et Madame Michu qui échange
en France entre Paris et et Melin par
exemple via un outil qui est installé à
l'étranger un outil Google ou Microsoft
ce que vous voulez ben
automatiquement si les service du
renseignement se focalise uniquement sur
l'adresse IP du service intermédiaire à
ce moment-là l'échange entre Fran
français va être euh considéré comme
internationale et cette qualification
internationale a des conséquences euh
très lourde en matière de formalisme et
de d'accompagnement du contrôle de ces
de ces de ces outils de surveillance
pourquoi parce que
euh euh la la cnctr donc et la
Commission nationale de contrôle des
techniques du renseignement n'intervient
pas à priori pour émettre non pas une
autorisation mais un avis elle
nintervient qu'à postériori
quand le mal est fait comment quand le
mal est fait quand le mal ou le bien est
fait tout
dépend effectivement lorsque lorsque la
communication met en relation il
apparaît que après auscultation la
communication met bien en relation de
personnes installé en France
effectivement il faut rebasculer sur sur
les le formalisme franco-français mais
c'est trop tard les services de
renseignement auront déjà eu
l'informationaravant la Commission donne
son avis mais c'est le premier ministre
qui signe et pour pour en revenir sur ce
que je disais tout à l'heure j'imagine
pas du tout la DGSE mettre sur les coup
Barack Obama sans que l'exécutif n'est
valider ce genre de chos par c'est untit
peu comme Angela Merkel écouté par la
NSA c'est-à-dire c'est l'exécutif é faut
de toute façon qu'à un moment il y a un
échelon qui effectivement valide le truc
parce que les petites mains qui vont
faire les écoutes vont pas prendre ce
genre d'initiative pour rien d'accord
même même les petites mains qui font de
l'écoute sur des candidats député bah
c'est ce qu'on a vu avec le très
intéressant la survillance de tir
solaire on a donc le monde qui titre
comment la DGSE surv tir solaire et
ensuite l'article qui explique que le
service technique la direction technique
de la DGSE a constaté un détournement
frauduleux des techniques de
renseignement de la DGSE a avisé le
magistrat de la DGSE qui a dit mais
c'est illégal qui est lui-même a avisé
le directeur de la DGSE qui a fait
cesser le détournement frauduleux et ce
qui est assez bizarre c'est de voir que
tout le monde a repris le fait que la
DGSE a survie tiré solaire alors que
nous ce qui explique le monde c'est que
la DJS a mis un terme un détournement
frauduleux de ces techniques de
renseignement Yassir
on fait quoi au milieu de tout ça les
entreprises comment elles font pour
éviter de se retrouver dans dans l' mail
du du chalu très large des services de
renseignement et préserver un
savoir-faire on fait comment pour très
bonne question alors la situation
aujourd'hui elle est assez
chaotique moi je fais partie de ceux qui
croient que dans ce ce ce chaos dans
lequel on baigne les hackeurs vont avoir
un rôle à jouer et je pense que c'est ce
qu'on est en train de ressentir petit à
petit et que tout le monde est en train
de prendre conscience que s'il y a une
population qui pourra aider aussi bien
les entreprises que les institutions
hein c'est c'est c'est c'est les ha cœur
parce que dans toutes ces situationsl ce
sont les personnes qui ont le profil
adéquat déjà de un pour comprendre la
complexité de l'architecture et des
architectures dans lesquell on baigne et
de deux qui sont armés pour pouvoir soit
anticiper des attaques soit répondre en
cas d'attaque donc aujourd'hui pourquoi
pourquoi ils sont pourquoi ils sont sont
c'est un vécu c'est un vécu ce sont des
gens P en dehors de la boîte c'est ça
alors il y a le fait moi je donne
toujours l'image de quand on regarde par
exemple Internet et qu'on regarde le
comportement des gens dessus si on veut
faire une analogie c'est vraiment on
peut faire une analogie avec
l'architecture urbaine vous avez les
citoyens les gens normaux qui vont
passer par le passage piéton et vous
avez les Yamakazi quoi ceux qui font le
parcours qui vont passer par la fenêtre
et c'est vraiment ça plus efficace c'est
pas plus efficace c'est vraiment une
autre lecture c'estàdire que quand on
regarde un browser on sait qu'il y a un
rending engine on sait qu'il y a un
moment un JavaScript on sait qu'à un
moment derrière il y a dev vient avec un
serveur on sait qu'il y a une librairie
quelque part alors que pour monsieur
tout le monde c'est une adresse sur
laquelle on clique et il y a des du
contenu qui s'affiche donc on a
unearchitecture de pensée qui est
différente voilà une manière de lire qui
est complètement différente et puis
aussi c'est des gens qui très tôt on
tombe dans cette idée de bidouiller des
systèmes et donc ça devient un mode de
vie plus qu'autre chose donc aujourd'hui
euh on a regardé une affaire comme
Panama papers c'estàd quand on regarde
que leur WordPress le WP include était
accessible à monsieur tout le monde
alors c'est peut-être du chinois ce que
je dis mais en gros c'est un répertoire
qui contenait tous les fichiers de
configuration entre autre app on on se
rend compte moi j'ai pas de doute sur le
fait qu'ils ont dépensé des des fortunes
monstrueuses pour acheter des firewall
ou je sais pas quoi ils ont jamais
penser à la confidentialité des dossiers
ça montre bien qu'en fin de compte la
sécurité c'est plus un état d'esprit
que juste des investissements financiers
dans du matériel ou autre chose et je
pense que aujourd'hui tout le monde est
en train de réaliser ça et j'insiste
vraiment je pense que les hackurs avec
les guillaumés qu'on peut mettre parce
qu'il y a un glissement quand même
sémantique du terme qui est très souvent
mélangé avec des cyberciminel je pense
un peu de l'idéal de cette idéeamalgame
classique en France voilà donc certains
ont essayé de donner le terme
bidouilleur cors je préfèreà Corsa mais
voilà cette population là va avoir un
rôle déterminé dans les années qui
viennent et je pense qu'ils sont en
train de se repositionner au au centre
même de des débats don qui sont en train
d'ê VO il il y a un million
d'utilisateurs de Facebook qui passent
par T qu on voit que WhatsApp a
implémenté un mécanisme de chiffrement
point point qui fait aujourd'hui il y a
plus d'un milliard de personnes qui
utilisent WhatsApp qui maintenant c'est
chiffré directement sur le téléphone
portable c'est chiffré avec quoi
d'ailleurs c'est chiffré avec la c'est
c'est l'application c'est la librairie
enfin la librairie c'est le logiciel qui
a développé muxi Parkinson Mii mxi euh
qui est celui qui a développé signal qui
est une application qui marche sur iOS
et sur sur Android et qui permet le
chiffrement point point c'estàdire que
le on tape le message il est en clair
sur le téléphone et quand on appuie sur
Entrer il est chiffré avec une clé de
notre correspondant donc ça circule sur
les réseaux de façon chiffrée c'est
déchiffré sur le téléphone du
correspondant et c'est extrêmement
simple à utiliser bien plus que tout ce
qui existait auparavant et un dernier
point la le mois dernier Google a
annoncé a fait un transparency report
sur le htpps donc depuis notamment
révélation snowon de plus en plus de
serveurs chiffr les les les transactions
ce qui circule sur le web et pour
prendre l'exemple de des utilisateurs
français des différents services Google
à l'exception de YouTube 81 % des
requêtes Google sont aujourd'hui
chiffrées donc même la DGSE à
l'international elle voit passer du
trafic chiffré donc quelqu'un qui
utilise Gmail avec quelqu'un qui utilise
une messagerie hot mail à partir du
moment où ils sont chiffrés entre eux
bah ça peut être intercepté sauf que ça
peut pas a priorire déchiffré euh oui il
y a une réponse parlementaire qui qui
est qui est très intéressante sur ces
question là de chiffrement et cetera ou
je crois que c'était le ministère de la
Défense ou deintérieur je m'en souviens
plus excusez-moi expliquer que le le
chiffrement des flux finalement c'est
c'est bon c'était pas si embêtant que ça
dans la mesure où la loi les différentes
lois la loi sur renseignement la loi sur
la surveillance de communication
internationale on a la loi sur la
réforme pénale projet de loi sur la
réforme pénale qui est actuellement
discuté qui passera en commission mixte
paritaire dans quelques jours autorise
aussi bien les services administratifs
que les autorités judiciaires à
installer des chevaux de 3 bleu blanc
rouge sur les extrémités des
communications donc du coup on a beau
avoir l'impression d'être dans une bulle
sécurisée un bnker avec des barreaux aux
fenêtres des voiles des rideaux noirs et
cetera en réalité bah son téléphone peut
très bien être sculé à distance par une
autorité sombre et cachée dans le coin
de la rue je je vais rebondir sur ça
j'ai un de mes amis un ancien de la DGSE
que vous connaissez tous euh qui m'a
parlé de 128 O de mémoire dans les
contrôleurs clavi c'est pas beau ça 128
Mo de mémoire dans les contrôleurs
clavier c'est-à-dire que ça peut stocker
jusqu'à 2 millions de frappes de vos
claviers un kiloger comment un kiloger
un enregistreur de frappe l'équivalent
d'un kiloger mais directement dans dans
le matériel donc si vous avez 2 millions
de frappes stocké en clair c'est ce que
disait Marc c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
chiffrer le point à point si vous êtes y
ouais euh ça renvient ça renvoie l'idée
du du enfin l'idée du bac d'or ou le
cheval de TR ou la porte
dérobée je pense que fondamentalement on
pense tous à au débat qu'il y a eu entre
le FBI et Apple ou le FBI pousser Apple
pour installer des et c'est vrai qu'il y
a eu des réactions assez bizarre en
France de gens débutés qui soutenaient
l'idée queil fallait mettre des bacs
d'or sur les sur les téléphones
portablebles ça pose un problème
pourquoi il ça pose un problème parce
que cette idée làà fondamentalement elle
est foncièrement bête c'est-à-dire que
on va équiper tous les téléphones iPhone
par exemple pour ne citer que cela avec
une porte dérobée une porte dérobée
c'est quoi c'est un accès privilégié qui
va être détourné alors ça peut être la
possibilité d'avoir un accès distant une
sorte de lien par lequel on pourrait
arriver à une console d'administration
ou autre on pourrait installer un un
shell qui permettrait à la personne qui
a expliquer Chelle parce que tout le
mond un code enfin une sorte de code qui
va s'exécuter qui pourrait nous donner
un accès à distance ou voilà mais en
tout cas c'est cette idée de à l'insu de
l'utilisateur final on a la capacité
d'accéder à des données et donc nous et
donc nous alors c'est très très beau
dans le monde des bisounours parce que
effectivement on pourrait imaginer que
ça pourrait être utilisé pour traquer
des méchant toujours est-il que cette
porte dérobée elle fin elle finira par
être connue par tout le monde alors
quand je dis par tout le monde bien
entendu c'est aussi bien par des
cyberciminels que par des terroristes et
je ne pense pas qu'ils vont hésiter à
utiliser ça donc c'était assez assez
flippant quelque part de voir que des
gens ne percutent pas encore le le
danger que puisse représenter le fait
d'avoir des portes dérobées sur des
machines utilisées par des millions de
alors pour résumer trivialement c'est
l'équivalent de donner un pass à toutes
les autorités qui sont censées enquêter
et que si un jour ce Pass tombe dans les
mains de personnes euh malintentionné ça
leur donne accès à tout c'est-àdire y
compris à votre vie privée les secrets
de entreprise euh écouter un PDG c'est
bien écouter un PDG très très bien Marc
ouais euh je je vais simplement revenir
sur le début de notre échange où vous
évoquez la lutte contre le terrorisme et
son efficacité et Jean-Marc disait très
très justement que cette lutte a
visiblement failli puisque on a eu ces
ces malheureux attentats
euh je tiens à nouveau à préciser que la
loi sur le renseignement et celle sur la
surveillance des communications
internationales n'est pas focalisée sur
le terrorisme terrorisme c'est qu'une
brique hein dedans on a des on a de la
la la politique étrangère de la
euhpionage économique économique et
cetera la lutte contre la criminalité
organisée ou enfin plutôt la prévention
de la criminalité organisée et autre
chose au fil des débats parlementaires
dans le texte initial dans le projet de
loi initial qui avait été déposé par
Christian tobira leedrian et casenu il
était dit que les services devaient euh
assurer la défense d'une série
d'intérêts il en avait 5 ou si en début
de d'échang parlementaires à la fin euh
de de des débats parlementaires cette
notion de de défense a été enrichie avec
celle de promotion donc ce qu' veut dire
par là c'est que les services du
renseignement peuvent aussi bien assurer
la défense des intérêts économiques
français en France comme à l'étranger
mais également faire en sorte de de de
de muscler ou de promouvoir ces
intérêtsl dans
planète entière c'està-dire avoir un
comportement prédateur c'est oui on on
passe d'une d'une technologie de de de
défense à une technologie d'attaque et
ça peut se cumuler et voilà et le
terrorisme même si d'après les chiffres
fournis par par Monsieur Delon président
de la Commission nationale de contrôle
et technique du renseignement montre que
le terrorisme correspond à à 40 % des
avis qui ont été délivrés euh par cette
commission depuis octobre entre octobre
et février euh 2016 euh on a d'autres
éléments comme ça qui rentrent dans la
boucle et qui permettent à la à aux
autorités de de flairer d'autres
d'autres flux qui qui ont inversant plus
plus plus monétaire plus économique
jeanmar jusqu'à l'année dernière euh au
niveau des des interceptions ciblées
donc quand je parlais des 6000 grosso
modo interceptions euh c'était plus de
50 % 60 % c'était la lutte contre le
crime organisé et 30 % c'était le
terrorisme donc là depuis cette année on
a effectivement un accroissement en
matière de de lutte contre le terrorisme
mais il faut bien comprendre que
l'essentiel du travail par rapport aux
écoutes téléphoniques des services de
renseignement c'est le crime organisé
parce que c'est les criminells sont plus
promptes à dire des conneries au
téléphone que ne sont les terroristes
euh petite précision c'est les chiffres
qui sont donnés euh et par toi et par
mois ne concerne que euh les dispositifs
de surveillance ou la vie de la CNCT est
nécessaire à priori et donc pas euh pour
la surveillance internationale où on ne
sait absolument rien évidemment tout est
couvert par le secret défense euh donc
classe on a aucune visibilité sur le sur
le la quantité d'information et le la
seule chose qu'on sait c'est c'est
effectivement c'est le papier de Vincent
jaauvert qui est un journaliste
spécialisé sur ces questions qui avait
sorti ça en juillet ça avait fait
beaucoup moins de bruit que la loi
enseignement mais un papier très
intéressant dans Le Nouvel Observateur
et qui disait qu'il y avait chaque année
grosso modo une quarantaine soixantaine
de cibles étaient désigné pour la
surveillance internationale sachant
qu'une c ça peut être un pays donc donc
voilà dernier point sur les chiffres
pour revenir à à à la au bac d' au
logiciel espion les logiciels espion euh
ont été autorisés il y a quelques années
en matière de police judiciaire parce
que là on parle que des services de
renseignement on parle pas des écoutes
téléphoniques en matière de police
judiciaire et un rapport très
intéressant de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement qui a été
publié il y a quelques mois expliquait
que vu la complexité technique et
administrative d'utiliser des logiciels
espions depuis 2011 ils n'ont été
utilisés que six fois en matière de
police judiciaire sur un pays en matière
de police judiciaire en matière de
police judiciaire en France euh on ne
sait pas pour ce qui est des services de
renseignement par contre ce qu'on sait
c'est que ce même rapport de la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement expliquait que à ce jour
les logiciels espion n'ont pas encore
été et vous y croyez ça c'est c'est
c'est un vrai problème de de de euh
est-ce que on peut avoir confiance dans
quelle institution j'ai plus tendance à
avoir confance sincèrement moi j'ai j'ai
un politique qui me dit ça que on n' pas
la capacité de traiter tous les flux
d'informations ou les logiciels espions
ou toute le le le flux d'information
qu'on peut faire émerger des des
logiciels espions je le regarde dans les
yeux j'ai dit tu te fous de ma gueule
mon pote enfin ce que ce que dit
Jean-Marc ce sont des magistrats qui euh
nationale ou au Sénat qui s'était plein
justement de disposer d'un outil
juridique afin de mener à bien des
enquêtes extrêmement intrusives pour la
vie privée mais justifié par des
finalités très importante parce qu'on
est là en terme de criminalité
criminalité organisée et de de
terrorisme bon on c'est pas rien mais il
se plaignait justement d'un d'un manque
de collaboration entre les autorités
administratives compétentes en ce
secteur-là et puis le ministère de
justice il a une espèce de de de cassure
comme ça après ce qu'il en est en
réalité moi je n'en sais
rien je répondrai à ta question sur
est-ce que enfin je peux répondre à ta
question allez vas-y est-ce que j'y
crois le truc c'est que il y a plein de
choses que je ne sais pas parce que j'ai
pas le besoin d'en connaître pour
reprendre l'expression consacré dans les
services de renseignement par contre ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'il y a des
choses que je peux que je peux fa
checker que je peux vérifier donc non je
n'ai aucun moyen de savoir si c'est vrai
qu' 6 uniquement logiciel qui aurait été
isé légalement par contre à partir du
moment où c'est un rapport officiel qui
est signé par des par des responsables
politiques qui est signé par des
magistrats ça engage la parole de l'État
donc moi le jour où j'arrive à démontrer
que c'est faux je me ferai un plaisir de
faire le papier pour l'instant tout ce
que je peux dire c'est rapporter les
chiffres auquels j'ai pu accéder
d'accord un complément parce que je
pense qu' qu' on le dit à demi-mot
depuis le début mais qu'il faut insister
dessus je pense qu'il faut vraiment se
dire que les logiques de guerre qu'on
connaissait sur des territoires
géographiques sont transposé dans ce
qu'on appelle le cyberespace des fois de
manière intelligente des fois de manière
beaucoup moins intelligente mais en tout
cas c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
avec les interconnexions qu'on a
qu'est-ce qu'on a on a par exemple des
pays qui pourraient être potentiellement
des cibles danst toutes les
administrations sans par exemple se
retrouve sur des serveurs Microsoft donc
potentiellement on pourrait accéder à
les finances de ce pays- là les données
de santé les paiements des citoyens et
cetera et cetera vous imaginez bien que
si vous avez accédé à ces Dom là vous
pouvez quand même faire des choses assez
dramatiques pour ce pay on peut aller
plus loin Microsoft pour voilà on peut
arriver sur des archit on peut arriver
par exemple sur des architectures pardon
SCADA donc là où on arrive à quelque
chose de très industriel c'est
industriel c'est l'informatique qui
contrôle des process industriel
exactement voilà donc là où l'impact il
va être physique on peut aller encore
plus loin je joue pas à la personne qui
veut faire peur mais je me dis il
faut de manière assez lucide et froide à
un moment pour pour mener là on est on
est en train de parler d'un quelque
chose qui est magnifique qui est l'IoT
qui est l'Internet des Objets l'internet
des objets pour faire moi j'aime bien la
la la définition de Jeremy Rifkin c'est
la rencontre du monde des digites et le
monde des atomes donc en gros avec
Internet on a construit une sorte de
squelette et puis là avec les capteurs
on va venir faire les terminaisons
nerveuses quoi donc on va pouvoir avec
des sites web interagir avec des choses
du monde réel donc vous imaginez bien
que les pays qui auront la capacité de
contrôler ce genre de chos ils pourront
potentiellement arrê arrêter le courant
électrique dans un pays je me rappelle
plus quel rapport peut-être que vous
allez vous rappeler d'un rapport qui
disait que aux États-Unis s' y a une
coupure d'électricité pendant une
semaine au bout d'une semaine c'est les
émeutes 48 he 48 he je crois c'est une
semaine c'était l'attaqueait fait Éric
Filiol et qui devait faire une
conférence aux États-Unis on lui a fait
comprendre qu'il fallait pas qu'il aille
faire la conférence aux États-Unis voà
donc du coup c'est et il faut quand même
prendre conscience que c'est pas juste
je capte des informations parce que au
moment internet on le réduit à je je lis
des messages ça donne un côté un peu
gentillé quoi là où il y a vraiment de
vrais enjeux derrière et que il faut
concevoir ça comme un vecteur
d'interception et si on n pas lu Carl
von closevit sur la guerre totale on
peut pas appréhender correctement ce
qu'on peut faire avec l'internet des
objets et toute l'interception des datas
donc pour revenir sur
l'interception et faire émerger du
renseignement exploitable de tout ça si
on fait passer de l'intelligence
artificielle derrière ces flux de
données plus un bon opérateur qui est
capable de de faire l'alliance entre
homme et la
machine ça va bien se passer on peut pas
traiter plus plus de six dossiers en
même temps qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez allez on n'hésite pas à se faire
peur hein al deux choses d'abord juste
pour pour revenir là-dessus c'est
c'était une interview qu'on avait fait
de Bernard barbier qui est l'ancien
directeur technique de la DGSE donc
c'est celui qui entre autres a déployé
les systèm de collect de masse au niveau
de la surveillance internationale qui
expliquait dans dans un documentaire
qu'on a fait sur la cybergerre il y a
pas très longtemps que euh il y a un
problème avec l'arme informatique
notamment l'arme offensive fait un
logiciel espion ou un logiciel comme
Stuxnet qui est donc un logiciel qui a
justement fait fait dérailler fait péter
des centrifugeuses iraniennes c'est que
la grosse différence entre une arme
informatique et une bombe normale c'est
qu'une bombe normale quand elle tombe
elle explose tu peux pas la récupérer
euh un logiciel comme stocknet ou un
logiciel espion type de ceux qui sont
utilisés par la police judiciaire ou des
services de renseignement ils explosent
pas il peuvent être conçuit pour
s'autodétruire pour disparaître sauf que
en espèce txnet a été repéré et que une
des choses qu'il expliquait c'est que
eux ils faisaient aussi très très
attention au logiciel qu'ils utilisaient
pour s'infiltrer dans des dans dans des
serveurs parce que si jamais d'aventure
ils sont identifiés par les adversaires
ils peuvent être réutilisés et c'était
un des problèmes auquels les services de
renseignement américains et israélien
ont été confrontés stxnet c'est que
maintenant les Iraniens ont aussi stxnet
et ils peuvent le détourner et c'est le
problème qu'on a rencontré également
avec les logiciel de hacking team ou de
fin Fisher alors hing teaming teams qui
est une entreprise italienne qui
développe un logiciel qui s'appelle RCS
ou Galileo remote contrô système contô
la distance qu'un logiciel qu'ils disent
ne vend qu'exclusivement à des services
de renseignement à des pays qui vaut
plus de 200000 € à l'année en règle
générale donc ça ça coûte très très cher
et qu'un logiciel espion qui qui est
conçu de telle sorte qu'il ne puisse pas
être connu par les an virus donc il y a
eu ils ont fait fin Fisher c'est une
entreprise allemande qui développe un
logiciel équivalent une suite de
logiciel équivalent qui peuvent
s'infiltrer que ce soit sur des serveurs
sur des ordinateurs ou prendre le
contrôle de téléphone portable par des
techniques qui sont maintenant
relativement documenté parce que
justement ils ont fait l'objet d'un
piratage et que leurs données internes
ont été rendu public parce que également
il y a eu des logiciels de hacking team
qui ont été identifiés parce qu'on
s'estaperçu qu'il y avait des dissidents
ou des journalistes qui avaient été
espionnés par ce logiciel là et que le
logiciel espion a été décortiqué
par par une une université canadienne
qui a expliqué comment ça fonctionnait
donc on a plus de visibilité et ça c'est
une des choses qui fait vraiment très
peur à la fois au militaire au service
de renseignement c'est qu'on arrive à
identifier pour une des raisons pour
lesquell ils étaient verts suite au
révélation Snowden c'est qu'ils arrivent
à révéler comment il fonctionnent
qu'est-ce qu'ils font parce que bah à
partir du moment où on sait comment ils
procèd et ben on peut éventuellement
prendre des mesures correctives confire
bah le fait que il y a plein de de
d'entreprises qui ont recruté énormément
de hackurs depuis les révélations
Snowden pour durcir internet c'était la
fameuse phrase de de Bruce schneyer qui
est un des meilleurs experts et
vulgarisateurs en matière de de sécurité
informatique qui disait que pour lutter
contre la surveillance de masse il faut
durcir internet pour faire de telle
sorte que massivement on utilise le
chiffrement et pour contraindre les
services de renseignement à ne procéder
qu' a des interceptions ciblées oui mais
on a bien on a bien montré que le le le
le chiffrement pouvaitêtre excusez-moi
l'expression mais on pouvait baiser le
chiffrement très facilement tu peux
baiser le chiffrement à partir du moment
où tu as installé un logiciel espion
dans le terminal de la cible en question
mais c'est même chose d'infiltrer le
terminal d'une cible en particulier que
de surveiller l'intégralité de tous les
Français et puis c'est pas faut pas
croire que c'est pas la même chose que
de casser la clé qui permet de casser la
clé c'est difficile après ce qu' fa bien
comprendre également c'est de logiciel
espion je pense qu'il y a beaucoup plus
de risque d'avoir un logiciel espion
installé dans ton ordinateur ou dans le
mien de la part de tes collègues de ton
patron de tes de ta femme ou de ton mec
ou de barbouse d'une entreprise
étrangère que d'un service de
renseignement qui soit français ou ou
étranger et je pense qu'on a beaucoup
depu révélation snon on s'est focalisé
sur la NSA sur le GCHQ qui est son
équivalent britannique sur la DGSE mais
on n' pas beaucoup parlé de ce que font
les Russes et de ce que font les Chinois
et on a encore moins parlé de ce que
font tous ces anciens des services de
renseignement qui bossent dans des
entreprises d'intelligence économique
euh ou ou d'espionnage parce que je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup plus
d'espionnage privé qu'il n'y a
d'espionnage public tout à fait Marc
Marc Marc Marc Marc enfin moi quand
j'entends tout ça je vois je je vois des
oreilles de partout des des yeux de
partout des des neés de partout des
moustaches des moustaches aussi petites
grande je ne sais pas et euh moi ce qui
m'intéresse là-dessus parce que je je je
trouve plutôt simple pour un état euh
démocratiquement abouti euh d'avoir
comme
ça une possibilité enfin un potentiel de
euh d'intrusion par rapport à des
infractions ou un risque infractionnel
extrêmement grave il est normal et
d'ailleurs c'est le c'est le job de
l'État et en tout cas de ces
gouvernement que de prévenir ces ces
infractionsl mais moi quand j'entends
tout ça ce qui dans ce ce ce combat
absolu entre la sécurité et la liberté
c'est il se résout simplement c'est
l'organe de contrôle l'organe de
contrôle aujourd'hui en France je
j'évoque même pas la la surveillance de
communication des communications
international mais en France celui-ci B
il faut lire un petit peu les les
différents avis qui ont été sécrétés par
les CNCT depuis octobre c'estàdire sa
mise en route depuis octobre 2015
celle-ci n'a de cesse de dénoncer le
manque de centralisation des
informations collectées parce qu'on a
effectivement dans la loi une panoplie
absolument folle d'outils intrusifs qui
vont récupérer de la donnée de partout
aussi bien sur le téléphone que sur les
flux et cetera et cetera mais ces
informations là pour qu'on puisse
contrôler la respectabilité
euh de la loi à savoir si les autorités
ont bien respecter la norme votée par
les députés et sénateurs et bien il faut
que l'autorité de contrôle puisse
contrôler et il a pas V que faute de
centralisation des informations
collectées et ben l'autorisation de
contrôle l'autorité de contrôle peut
difficilement contrôler elle l'objet de
courir dans toute la France pour aller
collecter les données qui sont qui sont
glanées ici et là alors est-ce que c'est
fait exprès pas exprès ça non c'est
inérant à la technologie le truc c'est
que avant les écoutes téléphoniques
étaient centralisés au GIC ils sont
encore centralisés au au GIC donc le
contrôle il est relativement simple à
faire une balise IMS catcher quand tu
l'installes à Marseille ben elle est pas
à côté de l'école milita au GIC et par
définition lesimsic catcher tu peux pas
le centraliser et donc c'est
effectivement ce que ce que ce que
contestait l'ancien président de la
CNCIS pourquoi il a pas voulu postuler à
la CN CTR c'est qu'effectivement il y a
une impossibilité matérielle euh de
contrôle parce que on peut pas mettre un
une personne du GIC derrière chèque
Balis musicatcher qui qui peut être
utilisé donc ils sont en train de
déployer des systèmes pour arriver à
faire remonter les informations mais
c'est c'est ça voilà c'est c'est un peu
compliqué est-ce c'est l'équivalent euh
d'avoir du nucléaire sans du contrôle du
nucléaire pour revenir sur ta question à
savoir est-ce que c'est fait exprès ou
pas
euh j'espère que non euh je note
simplement que dans l'étude d'impact
lorsque vous un gouvernement dépose un
projet de loi il doit impérativement
associer celui-ci à une étude d'impact
où il va essayer de chiffrer euh
calibrer l'impact économique des mesures
qu'il envisage de faire voter par les
députés sénateurs pourquoi parce que bah
ça budget le budget de la Nation budget
public et il faut qu'on sache où va la
contribution et curieusement et cétait
relevé par aucun député ni sénateur euh
sauf erreur euh le projet de loi sur le
renseignement est totalement silencieux
sur le paquet de bifeton qui va être mis
ou qui est mis aujourd'hui sur le bureau
de la cncttr on a appris par la suite
que la cnctr se verrait attribuer 400000
€ pour l'année là actuellement il y a 9U
membres plus se personnes employées à la
fin de l'année il y aura une vingtaine
de personnes employées mais voilà on a 9
membres une vingtaine de personnes fin
2016 un budget de 400000 € tout ça pour
surveiller théoriquement l'intégralité
des flux qui sont qui sont collectés ici
et là aussi bien aussi bien en contrôle
à priori pour la surveillance française
qu'en contrôle à postériori pour la
surveillance française et internationale
ça me fait penser à au au
sousdimensionnage de l'enquête
parlementaire américaine sur le 11
septembre c'est extraordinaire non
c'estàd que vous avez une enquête vous
avez une enquête vous avez une enquête
vous avez une enquête qui qui commence
avec un budget très minime qui est sans
fois inférieure à l'enquête sur
l'affellation de Bill Clinton Jean-Marc
Manac voulez dire quelque
choseation du temps de la CNCIS comme du
temps de la CNCT leurs présidents
respectifs disent que même si
effectivement ils ont pas beaucoup de
ils sont pas nombreux euh quand il y a
urgence ils arrivent à répondre en
quelques dizaines de minutes ou en moins
de 24 heures au pire euh ou en et en 2
heures quand il y a vraiment urgence
donc c'est c'est pas le problème
d'effectif ne se porte pas par rapport à
l'urgence le problème effectivement là
c'est qu'il y a plus de techniques de
renseignements qui ont été validés par
la loi qui existait déjà auparavant
c'est juste qu'il y avit pas de cadre
légal qui ont permettait l'utilisation
Mo quand je vous entends dire ça j'ai
l'impression d'entendre les gens du
nucléaire me dire vous inquiétez pas on
a une capacité de réaction qui est
extraordinaire regardez Fukushima on a
tout bien géré hein ça fait pas un peu
comme ça c'est plus comme s'il y avait
un camion qui tournait avec des flingues
et que n'importe qui pouvait rentrer
dedans et servir avec un fling et et
continuer de de tourner qu pas tout à
fait d'accord par que ça fait pas la
cybergerre ça fait des cyber morts pour
prendre l'expression Antoine champagne
c'est il y a pas ça a pas la même le
même niveau de létalité physique que que
le nucléaire pour l'instant
effectivementle dans 25 ans par rapport
à l'interet des objets
ils sont où les morts bah les morts si
moi je m'amuse à aller à sticoter un
petit peu les centrales nucléaires
t'inquiète pas que les Mor après les
morts on peut les trouver autrement
c'està dire dans la capacité à
géolocaliser des gens qu'on veut
éliminer ça après on peut faire
l'exercice de se dire c'est pas direct
c'est pas un mort directima ou pendant
des des
siècles un territoire pas êre un
territoire mais une démocratie peut être
plombée quand même non pas pendant des
siècles mais pendant des décenes en 945
s av les capacités par des boes noir
parlons des boîtes noires parce que
c'est ça les boîtes noires c'est la
chose qui a fait le plus flipper
l'opinion publique et pas seulement
l'opinion publique les médias enfin j'ai
jamais vu autant
d'opposition per couper si tu me permets
de te couper j'ai pas peur des boîtes
noir moi personnellement je sais m'en
préserver ça ça me fait pas peur moi ce
qui me fait peur c'est qu'on donne tout
un tas de LAM de rasoir à les
incompétent avec une parole démocratique
française qui est souillée et des lames
de rasoir dans un contexte économique
gravissime
ces existaient c'est juste que elles
existaient elles étaient utilisées mais
que il y avait pas de cadre légal qui
qui en autorisaient officiellement
l'utilisation il y a deux il y a deux
nouvelles techniques de renseignement
qui ont été introduites dans la loi
renseignement qui n'existait pas
auparavant la première c'est les
fameuses boîtes noires en fait les
boîtes noires c'est quoi c'est un fail
politico-médiatique c'est un conseiller
ministériel qui quand on quand des
journalistes ont demander mais c'est
quoi la surveillance algorithmique les
algorithmes de surveillance que vous
voulez légaliser dans le renseignement
le Conseil ministériel a dit vous
inquiétez pas c'est des boîtes noires il
y a rien qui en sortira depuis c'est
devenu un phénomène les boîtes noires
alors qu'en fait on parle bien de
d'algorithme de surveillance euh et en
fait c'est quoi c'est parce que la
technologie évolue et ils ont signé ils
ont légalisé donc ses algorithme de
surveillance en se disant bon ben on
sait pas comment la technologie va
évoluer mais on va se permettre un
algorithme de surveillance ça veut tout
dire n'importe quoi ça veut dire un
logiciel grosso modo donc on va voir on
légalise ça dès maintenant comme ça on
aura déjà un cadre légal le jour où on
voudra les mettre en œuvre gen et la
deuxième mesure qui a été qui n'existait
pas auparavant et qui a été légalisée
par la loi renseignement c'est la
surveillance en temps réel des
métadonnées de tout ceux qui
communiquent avec les cibles ce qui
représent une menace pourquoi parce
qu'on avait découvert suite aux
attentats de Charlie que les frères
Kashi et Koulibali ne communiquer pas
directement avec leur téléphon mais
passer par les téléphones de leur
conjointes respective donc pour arriver
à identifier des nouveaux terroristes
ils veulent surveiller les métadonnées
de tous ceux qui communiquent avec les
cimes passit pas que comme ça pas que 5
tout F en un an non mais sans trahir mes
sources sans trahir mes sources mais bon
je pense que je vais être encore écouté
pour les 50 prochaines années euh il
passait aussi par des boîtes mail non
pas du tout je sais pas il se laissaiit
pas des petits messages dans les les
poubelles des boîtes mail ou dans les
dossiers pas encore envoyés non sais
j'ai pour ce qui est des quashi
Coulibali je sais pas il y en a d'autres
qui effectivement utilisaient des des
applis mais juste reviens sur ce TR app
non non c'est simplement tu prends
n'importe quelle boîte mail tu laisses
un message dans le dossier pas envoyé tu
files le code à ton pote et puis euh
qu'utiliser le général petraus avec sa
maîtresse et pouro serré aux États-Unis
c'est ce que certains terroristes
auraient utilisé c'est ce qu'utilise
également un des journalistes de cache
investigation avec le lanceur d'alerte
au Luxembourg c'est comme ça qu'il
s'échanga des des messages c'est une des
techniques utilisées je reviens juste
sur la loi renseignement donc c'est ce
sont les deux innovations dans la loi
renseignement de choses qui n'existaient
pas auparavant et j'en reviens au
rapport de la délégation parlementaire
au renseignement il y a une note de bas
de page la note 67 ou 128 je sais pas
quoi qui dit que du fait de la
complexité technique et administrative
la surveillance en temps réel des
métadonné d'une part et les les les
fameuses boîtes noires les algorithmes
de surveillance des comportements
suspects d'autre part ne sont pas mis en
œuvre aujourd'hui donc l'essentiel du
débat l'année dernière àortter sur
quelque chose qui n'existe toujours pas
à en croire la délégation parlementa des
a designé qui est desj designé pour être
utilisé
oui mais pour pour l'instant ça reste
effectivement de l'ORD d'une menace
virtuelle et moi ce que j'avais aussi
essayé d'expliquer l'année dernière
c'est que contrairement à ce que on
entendait à savoir que les boîtes noires
allaient surveiller l'intégralité de
tout le trafic des Français on
journalist
encore chur de lineria qui a dit que
c'était complètement débile parce que si
on surveille 66 millions de Français
avec un taux d'erreur même si c'est 99 %
de taux d'erreur il a énormément de gens
qui qui n'ont rien à se reprocher qui
sont surveillés sauf que les services
sont pas complètement débiles pour
voouvoir surveiller 66 millions de
Français d'une part et que d'autre part
techniquement parlant c'est impossible
de surv l'intégralité du trafic Internet
français parce qu'il faud déployer 50 à
70000 boîtes noires au niveau des dlam
parce que l'internet c'est décentraliser
il y a des paquets qui vont passer par
Rennes des paquets qui vont passer par
lillele et que pour arriver
effectivement à regrouper ces paquets là
bah il faudrait mettre des boîtes noires
un peu partout et que ça coûterait des
milliards d'euros et que voilà donc tu
me parles de nucléaire je te renvoie les
boîtes noires il faut bien c'est c'est
un truc de de base en matière de
sécurité informatique c'est le modèle de
menace quel est le modèle de menace
auquel on est confronté moi ce que je
découvre en enquêtant par que quand tout
le monde a commencé à parler de la NSA
moi j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à la
DGSE pour voir qu'est-ce qu'il faisait
et ce qui est très intéressant de voir
c'est que pour une bonne partie du débat
concernant les moyens des services de
renseignement laisse entendre que sont
ils font exclusivement la surveillance
de masse ou surtout de la sur de masse
alors que moi ce que je vois c'est que
c'est beaucoup plus de surveillance
ciblée ne serait-ce que parce que ils
sont pas non plus 100000 300000 et que
bah des gros volumes de données faut
faut un moment des analystes à la NSA
ils sont moins de 50000 à la DGSE ils
sont moins de 6000 et ils ont pas que ça
à [__] par ailleurs Marc ouais ben
j'étais là moi lors de cette cette
microonférence de presse où le ministère
enfin le gouvernement allait expliquer à
trois vagues de journalistes la loi
renseignement qu'il allait déposer à
l'Assemblée nationale quelques jours
plus tard effectivement ce conseil
technique a évoqué ce terme de boîte
noire mais dans un sens positif à savoir
que pour lui il avait cette logique
aéronautique on avait une boîte noire
qui allait être installée chez des
pilotes d'avion un peu bizarres qui sont
des opérateurs et euh où l'opérateur
n'aurait aucun droit d'entrée de
contrôle de connaissance donc
faites-nous confiance voilà et
effectivement effectivement il y a eu un
effet boomerang euh voilà mais après bon
c'est le jeu euh après effectivement
comme tu dis Jean-Marc on va pas écouter
tout le monde mais j'allais dire et
alors je dis et alors enfin ça change
absolument rien parce que lorsquon tu
avances
ainsi tu avances de tels arguments on
pourrait croire en creux ou à contrario
que dans la mesure ça ça pas être tout
le monde ben finalement c'est un peu
moins grave non enfin pour moi je me
fiche totalement de savoir si the boîte
noire va va va va récolter va glaner
chalutter l'intégralité des données ou
la moitié des données de la population
française ou un/3 ou un centiè ou ou 1
milliè euh enfin pour moi ça n'a aucune
importance ce qui m'intéresse plus c'est
cette notion de contrôle
euh sur sur le possible champ du
possible de des
services sur l'analyse que va pouvoir
avoir toujours la cncttr je suis un peu
obsédé par elle mais parce que c'est le
dernier verrou avant du n'importe quoi
et pour l'instant moi j'ai j'ai pas de
réponse je je défi quiconque d'avoir des
réponses dans la mesure où tout est
classé défense secret défense onait bien
reondir sur deux choses qui ont été
dites et je pense que ça va être
intéressant parce que depuis tout à
l'heure on parle beaucoup de c'est
classique he on parle beaucoup de
sécurité on oublie la sûreté on parle
beaucoup de sécurité informatique et les
deux sont liés la pour faire un distingo
rapidement la sécurité ça va être pour
lutter contre ce qui est volontaire des
attaques volontaes quelqu'un a
volontairement voulu endommager là où la
sûreté ça serait comment lutter sur
contre des choses qui seraient
involontaires l'accident quoi et et je
pense que c'est vrai il faut se poser
aussi cette question là et qu'elle est
très souvent illucidée donc ça c'est
juste une remarque au passageudé et
voilà éludé et j'aimerais bien revenir
sur la l'affaire hacking team parce que
bon de 1 moi je connais très bien cette
affaire puisque moi j'ai j'étais dans un
collectif qui a priori jusqu'à preuve du
contraire on a été attaqué par un par un
outil de de hacking team ça va beaucoup
plus loin que des juste des des des des
outils de contrôle à distance parce que
eux il ils récupérraent ce qu'on appelle
du Z0 d du Z0 d ce sont des failles de
de de sécurité qui n'ont pas du tout
encore été patché inconnu par les
éditeurs et donc c'est patché c'est dire
pas encore corrigé par par l'éditeur en
question et donc du coup en terme
d'impact tant que ça n'a pas encore été
connu par l'éditeur l'impact peut être
faudoyant parce que toutes les machines
qui sont équipées ou potentiellement qui
contiennent cette vulnérabilité sont
suscepties d'être attaqué et on peut
exécuter des d'exploite dessus donc ce
que faisait cette boîte c'est que elle
récupérait des éod il il ont embarqué
n'importe comment un peu dans des dans
dans des outils et puis ça a été ça a
été revendu un peu partout a priori à à
à des gouvernement et donc ça renvoie à
cette question de se dire
euh une fois que les les les tout le
code source de hacking team s'est
retrouvé dans la nature puisque à leur
tour ils ont été hackés moi je maintiens
l'idée que on s'est retrouvé quand même
avec une sorte de d'un garage avec plein
d'armes informatique ou cyber si on veut
faire le
distingo quel plein de plein de monde se
sont servis et puis du coup même les
personnes qui utilisaient ces outils là
commencent à se dire bon bah est-ce que
je sais très bien utiliser est-ce que
moi-même je peux pas me faire attaquer
mais moi ça je veux aller encore plus
loin ça ça pose la question de la
réglementation c'estàd cette boîte
vendit légalement du z0d quoi il vendait
légalement des outils pour attaquer donc
une petite C nickov disponible dans une
voilà c'est ça et il y a une vraie
réflexion sur ce marché là et sur est-ce
que on peut vendre est-ce que ça fait
sens de vendre des vulnérabilités comme
ça non patché inconnu qui peuvent avoir
des impacts aussi dramatiques alors on
va changer de sujet on va parler des
whistleblowers je vais donner la parole
à Jean-Marc Jean-Marc les whistleblowers
Snowden Assange on en est où là l'asile
l'asile de snowon en France la position
de Michel Sapin sur les lanceurs
d'alertes il se passe quoi en France on
fait des belles pares snowon a alerté la
France a vraiment voulez défendre les
lanceurs d'alerte donc euh
accueillez-moi mais ils vont pas ils
vont pas le faire c'est c'est euh il
faut comprendre que euh c'est les fameux
five eyes donc les five c'est les
services de renseignement américains
britannique Canadiens néozélandais et
australiens qui ont formé cette alliance
dans les années 50 60 où il partage
plein de renseignements donc tout ce que
collecte la NSA n'est pas partagé avec
les five eyes mais une bonne partie de
ce qu'il collecte et derrière il y a
c'était un des graphes que qu' avait été
publié dans le cadre des révélations
Snowden il y a les nine eyes les sa eyes
en fait c'est des c'est c'est c'est des
accords de partenariat il faut voir ce
que font les services de renseignement
comme une place de marché c'est-à-dire
que je te file tant de données tu me
files t technologie il y av V eu cette
une du monde il y a quelques il y a y a
2 3 ans qui avait dit que la la NSA
espionné 70 millions de communications
téléphonique de français et mais
maintenant c'est plus ça hein en fait
c'était pas ça c'était 70000 70 millions
de métadonnées qui avaient été
intercepté à l'étranger sur un théâtre
de guerre d'opération par la DGSE qui
avait été partagé euh à à par la DGSE
qui avait partagé au five on sait qu'il
y a des accords de partenariat entre la
DGSE et le GCHQ tu me donnes tant de
millions de métadonnées qui viennent de
tel pays et je te file tant de millions
de métadonnées parce qu'ils ont des
objectif conjoint ils sont ensemble dans
la lutte contre daesh par contre ça va
pas empêcher la DGSE de pouvoir
espionner des Américains et des
Américains de pour espionner les
Français comme on l'a
montré c'est des accords entre les
services de renseignement pour partager
des technologies et partager du
renseignement alors dans les dans les
five euh je veux bien que et donc comme
ils ont des accords et ben ils vont la
France ne va pas accueillir Edward snden
parce que edor snodon n'est pas un ami
des États-Unis mais moi je vois plutôt
ça du moins on voit plutôt ça
différemment euh je pas si bien on voit
plutôt ça comme une technique de mafieux
qui dit voilà tu es attaqué par Al-Qaïda
si tu ne me donnes pas accès à tes
renseignements je ne te donnerait plus
accès à mon renseignement c'est ce qui
s'est passé pendant la première guerre
du Golf euh les militaires français se
sont aperçus que les militaires
américains refusaient de leur montrer
certaines photos satellites ce pourquoi
l'armée française a créé la direction du
renseignement militaire la DRM pour
arriver justement à pouvoir avoir des
satellites espions que ce soit pour
espionner des le spectre herdien les des
radars ou pour prendre des photos
satellites la France est un des rares
pays au monde à avoir effectivement une
capacité de de renseignement
satellitaire et c'est parce que les
Américains refusaient de partager Marc
est-ce que Michel Sapin se fout pas un
peu de la gueule du monde quand il dit
qu'il veut protéger les lanceurs d'Al
d'alerte j'attends que les différents
textes qui sont en discussion soi c'est
vrai que vous faites vous faites un
travail de Mo btin sur le texte de loi
et on tient tous à vous remercier de et
Benjamin Bayard aussi de ce côté moin de
bénédictin parce qu'il faut vraiment
qu'il y en a qui qui
amateur en fait c'est accessible à tout
le monde enfin si on a un petit bagage
initial c'est accessible à tout le monde
il suffit simplement de se se pluger sur
le site le site de l'Assemblée nationale
ou du Sénat regarder les amendements qui
sont déposés à droite à gauche par
sénateurs députés et par le gouvernement
et essayer de renifler quel sera
l'avenir il y a les tous les outils sont
là il y a cas dans l'espèce la note de
bas de page sur les boîtes noires qui
n'existe pas il y a eu je sais pas
combien d'articles à un dernière sur les
boîtes noires et il y a aucun article de
presse à ma connaissance sur cette note
de bas de page qui pourtant est une une
information que je trouve plutôt
intéressante alors sur les W juste une
petite remarque parce que il y a encore
un autre terme dont on parle souvent les
M les métadonnées peut-être que ça parle
pas à tout le monde mais en gros c'est
des données sur les données en gros tu
envoies le message et la madata ça va
être l'heure à laquelle ça a été envoyé
d'où ça a été envoyé qui a envoyé qui a
reçu donc quand on parle de metadata
c'est de la donnée sur de la donnée en
gros pour les whistlebur je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a un problème de
statut c'estàdire que il y a une sorte
et c'est un peu la la c'est c'est
classique à l'apparition d'un rôle dans
une société ou dans une organisation ou
l tout c'est queaujourd'hui le
whistleblower a un statut moral que
l'opinion publique lui reconnaît mais il
n'a pas du tout de statut légal et c'est
pas la même chose parce que il peut il
peut avoir tout le soutien moral du
monde les également on peut
l'emprisonner on peut le poursuivre il
peut avoir de sacrés problèmes et je
pense que ce qui est en train de se
jouer aujourd'hui c'est cette capacité à
créer un statut légal pour ces individus
et le cadrer au milieu de contraintes
qui dépassent juste des espaces
géographiques localisés puisque comme tu
disais très bien on se retrouve dans des
personnes qui peuvent avec leur
révélation embarquer tout un réseau
international dans une affaire voilà qui
deviendra une affaire géopolitique donc
je pense que là aujourd'hui c'est ce
moment-làù est-ce qu'on va va réussir à
passer d'un statut moral vers un statut
légal reconnu par la loi qui va de pour
le moment c'est pas clair c'est pas
gag enfin c'est extrêmement complexe à
encadrer juridiquement enfin c'est
effectivement cette C dichotomie entre
la morale et puis le juridique enfin
franchement le le pont est pas simple je
j'ai le la confortable place de pas être
législateur heureusement
et voilà il y a une tentative qui est
actuellement menée euh en matière de
faille informatique parce que vous savez
que lorsque vous avez un système
informatique vous rentrez dedans déjà si
vous rentrez dedans sans autorisation
c'est une infraction pénale si vous
maintenez à l'intérieur c'est une
infraction pénale si vous modifiez des
éléments c'est une infraction pénale
plus grave donc il y a toute une échelle
comme ça de de de peine qui est pré
programmé euh problème que se passe-t-il
lorsqu'un un Bluetooth par exemple
trouver une faille de sécurité sur un
sur un système
euh et les bruits voilà ou alors le
souffle l'existence de cette faille
sécurité à l'éditeur du système en
question donc là actellement le problème
des attaques blanches par reconnu en
France ouais voilà actuellement il il y
a un texte qui est qui est en gestation
je crois que c'est sur le projet de loi
sur la réforme pénale j'ai peut-être un
doute parce
que voilà qui vise à à ce que les les
lanceurs d'alerte en matière
informatique soi finalement excuser de
leur intervention de leur entrée dans un
alors excuser ça veut dire dispens
dispensé voilà dispensé de peine et
c'est là où ils sont pas dispensés de
poursuite c'est-à-dire qu'ils seront
poursuivis ils seront juger mais juste
avant la condamnation avant que le le
bourreau appuie sur sur le bouton rouge
euh et ben non la dispense de peine sera
là sauf que quand quand vous travaillez
dans la sécurité informatique et vous
avez un casier judiciaire c'est
compliqué quand même non c'est
extrêmement compliqué euh voilà d'autant
plus qu'il y a un amendement qui a été
euh qui est poussé par par l'opposition
qui voudrait que euh finalement ce soit
euh ce soit pas ce système-là qui qui
soit qui soit adopté en France mais un
mécanisme où euh les les Bluetooth de
France et de Navar viendrai euh souffler
à l'oreille de Lancy l'Agence nationale
de la sécurité et système d'information
l'existence d'une feuille de sécurité
chez X ou Y afin que celle-ci puisse
prendre les les mesures d'hygiène
informatique euh afin de de de colmater
tout ça mais là encore c'est c'est bien
beau mais ça n'interdira pas à à l'édit
propriétaire de système informatique
d'attaquer ce Bluetooth en question qui
vient qui vient pénétrer ses plat de
bandes sur ça moi c'est un sujet qui me
parle encore beaucoup parce que voilà
moi j'ai j'ai on on parlait tout à
l'heure je travaille sur une plateforme
que j'ai créé avec d'autres amis qui
s'appelle gocha et qui met en relation
les hackurs avec les entreprises et on
fait ce qu'on appelle du bug Banti
c'està dire que l'entreprise aujourd'hui
a des entreprises qui acceptent de payer
les hackeurs qui leur détectent des
failles de sécurité et je pense que ici
il y a une nouvelle voie qui est en
train de se dessiner et qui va justement
amener à créer une sorte de marché légal
transparent dans lequel on rentre dans
un process de service c'està-dire que le
hackur va dire à tel site regardez ici
vous avez tel faille et l'entreprise va
reconnaître ça comme une vraie
transaction professionnelle et va payer
pour pour le service qui aé r une prime
une incitation enfin ça c'est
la je te donne ici la réponse des
opposants intellégalist est-ce que c'est
pas une prime une espèce de carotte
àce que àce que tests un petit peu
sauvageons soient menés sur tel ou tel
système absolument pas parce que c'est
c'est des choses qui sont très cadrées
il faut savoir que c'est un modèle qui
existe par ailleurs aux États-Unis c'est
pas quelque chose
qui on n pas réinventé la roue c'est
quelque chose qui existe par ailleurs et
qui marche très très bien et l'idée
c'est que de un en quoi ça insisterait
les gens à à tester de manière sauvage
la deuxième chose qu'il faut savoir
c'est que euh nous par exemple on
sélectionne les gens qui travaillent sur
la plateforme c'est pas un truc ouvert
où n'importe qui peut venir faire
n'importe quoi donc à partir du moment
où il y a une vraie sélection et que il
y a un rapport enfin une plateforme bien
qui cadre les choses qui offre ce cadre
légal et qui en plus offre toutes les
protections on va dire techniques en
disant interdit d'utiliser des scans
automatiques interdit de faire ça il
faut travailler de telle plage horaire à
telle plage horaire les hackeurs sont
des gens qui connaissent ça qui le font
par ailleurs avec des plateformes
américaines par exemple donc ils sont
ils ont parfaitement tout ce qu'il faut
pour pouvoir faire le même service avec
des entreprises françaises qui
joueraient le jeu quoi et sur l'idée
juste je finis sur l'idée de l'autre cas
limite où un hackur ferait fuiter c'est
vrai qu'il y a une différence culturelle
par exemple avec les États-Unis les
États-Unis ce qu'on appelle le fa
discloser c'est-à-dire que un hackeur va
soumettre un un il pourrait dire par
exemple une une faille à une entreprise
et si l'entreprise ne se réveille pas ou
ne fait rien il va le rendre public et
la sécurité c'est aussi ça c'està-dire
au au bout d'un moment et ça marche très
très bien c'est dire au bout d'un moment
une entreprise qui fait pas son travail
qui ne protège pas qui ne protège pas
bah il faut en parler et il faut qu'il
se bouge le cul quoi c'est au bout d'un
moment il y a pas de et voilà c'est
cette culture là n'existe pas
encore en France mais je pense que ça va
venir d'autant plus que il va y avoir
par exemple un amendement qui se prépare
qui est déjà passé la la la cyberdective
sur la la protection des données
personnelles si je dis pas de bêtises où
les tout entreprise prise qui ne
communiquerait pas sur une perte ou des
ou un vol des données de ses
utilisateurs se verrait avoir une amende
de 5 % du chiffre d'affaires une
broutille ENF là actuellement cette
obligation existe sur les épaules des
opérateurs télécom voilà mais maintenant
d'accès et c le droit français é mis à
jour donc l'acnil peut être informé et
si jamais le l'acnil estime que le
fournisseur d'accès n'est pas super
coopératif
la possibilité de lui ordonner d'alerter
l'ensemble de son parc d'abonnés donc
c'est assez douloureux comme comme
manœuvre parce que en ce milieu plus que
l'argent c'est la confiance qui qui nous
tout doncors on va pass un orange un fr
peu importe oui alors un dernier mot sur
les lanceurs d'alerte et j'en profite
pendant que j'ai la parole il nous reste
5 minutes votre dernière question ce
sera laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations ça fait une heure qu'on est
déjà ensemble Jean-Marc les
whistleblowers et tout su sur les
lanceur on a jamais eu autant de
lanceurs d'alerte il y a jamais eu
également aux États-Unis aant de
lanceurs d'alerte qui sont poursuivis
par l'espionnage Act sous Obama il y en
a eu autant que depuis 1917 donc c'est
c'est une vraie lame de fond ça continue
et que ce soit du côté des militaires on
l'a vu là du côté des banques donc ça
c'est une sorte de cercle vertueux c'est
c'est il y a snodden qui vient de signer
un papier là qui est sorti hier sur des
intercept qui les présente comme des
nouveaux résistants on a eu un lanceur
d'aller des années 70 maintenant il y en
a plein donc ça c'est très très bien
après sur les limites du contrôle légal
de ce que peut faire la loi on a vu
suite au printemps arabe quand on a dé
ouver effectivement que des entreprises
occidentales avaient donné des logiciels
de surveillance ou des logiciels espion
enfin donné vendu à des dictateurs ils
ont changé les accords vasnar vasnar
c'est la régulation des biens double
usage des biens qui peuvent être
utilisés pour des utilisations civiles
ou militaires et normalement aujourd'hui
une entreprise française qui veut vendre
un logiciel espion un système de
surveillance à un pays étranger doit
demander l'autorisation en Matignon donc
ça c'est bien à priori dans la loi sauf
queon a pas de visibilité là-dessus on
sait pas exactement comment c'est fait
et on a vu que plusieurs entreprises
françaises ce sont délocalisés à
l'étranger dans des pays qui n'ont pas
signé les accords de vasenard pour
pouvoir continuer à vendre leur système
de surveillance donc c'est les limites
de la
légalité Marc un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
euh c'est ouais je tu as les enfants
j'ai des enfants mais alors la
laisseleur un conseil immortel sur
Internet
euh ça pas être super sexy mais
justement je je pense que je les
inciterai et là j'essaie tout doucement
les initi à ça à suivre les débats
parlementaires parce que c'est là ou
c'est là où tout se passe réellement
c'est là où tout se passe mais bon c'est
mon c'est mon ADN aussi c'est ma c'est
ma DOP ma drogue mais suivre les débats
parlementaires sur des questions de
société qui peuvent les intéresser
potentiellement c'est fondamental parce
que le politique est obligé de sortir du
bois on a des députés qui sont qui sont
un petit peu un petit peu painible et
qui pose des bonnes questions et des
noms des noms des noms oh je sais pas
moi il a a lional tard Isabel
atard christian Paul Patrick Bloche
notamment lorsqu'ils sont dans
l'opposition
euh voilà on a quelques députés comme ça
qui qui sort qui sortent qui peuvent
sortir du lot selon le contexte
environnant
et qui peuvent qui peuvent comme ça
nourrir le débat et puis contraindre le
politique quel que soit sa couleur
JeanMarc un conseil pour les jeune
génération
euh vérifierz si on vous dit quelque
chose si vous voyez quelque chose
vérifier est-ce qu'il y a un lien est-ce
qu'il y a une source regardez le code
source d'un logiciel apprenez à coder ou
si vous apprenez pas à coder apprenez à
comprendre le code à lire le code source
euh c'est euh parce que sinon si vous
êtes juste des pouces boutons euh pour
fororder pour non et et et moi ce qui me
fait le plus flippé c'est que quand je
suis quand je suis arrivé sur internet à
la fin des années 90 il y avait quelques
théoriciens de la conspiration quelques
conspirationnistes qui parlaient
d'Illuminati et cetera de reptilien le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
dans les cours de collège euh et et et
que et pas que dans les cours de de
collège c'est aussi des des de plus en
plus de gens notamment à l'extrême
droite quient complètement
conspirationnistes et c'est un le truc
qui me fait le plus flipper c'est ça en
ce moment c'est des gens qui partent
complètement VR à croire n'importe quoi
et et aussi je le déplore l'année
dernière avec la loi renseignement j'ai
vu plein de trucs de gens qui avaient
peur mais en fait si on vérifie si on si
si on regardait si on se renseignait on
aurait beaucoup moins peur et on a et et
je pense que on a moins peur de ce qu'on
connaît c'est pas un peu la faute des
journalistes qui est autant de
conspirationnistes maintenant parce que
comme ils ont pas fait leur taf pendant
20 end je te ben je on en revient on en
revient au papier on en revient à
l'histoire de la surveillance de Tiry
solaire le monde fait un titre avec un
article qui dit le contraire de ce que
dit le titre la totalité de la presse
reprend le titre alors que il de l
l'article totalité de la presse allez
Yassir le mot de la fin alors difficile
de donner un conseil bon je rejoins bien
sûr g Manac sur l'idée qu'il faut
regarder le code s'intéresser à la
technologie d'autant plus qu' on en
parlait tout à l'heure avec l'Internet
des Objets on va baigner dans des dans
des sociétés où ça va être vraiment
quelque chose d'important mais je pense
qu'il y a aussi une petite réflexion à
partager c'est de voir la technologie
comme un pharmacan je reprends l'idée de
de stigler qui est il faut le voir comme
aussi bien le médicament l'antidote que
le poison et donc la capacité à ne pas
trop s'enthousiasmer pour la technologie
et pas non plus partir sur quelque chose
de dramatique avoir toujours cette cet
équilibre de se dire on peut bien
l'utiliser on peut ne pas bien
l'utiliser comment on peut bien
l'utiliser quels serait les dangers de
l'utilisation de la technologie la
technologie reste qu même quelque chose
d'objectif en soi c'est l'humain qui est
subjectif messieurs merci je voulais
vous remci vous remercier au nom de
notre communauté d'être venu on aurait
pu discuter des heures et des heures
avec vous j'espère qu'on pourra
réorganiser un débat pour creuser plus
en profondeur les sujets qu'on a évoqué
aujourd'hui monsieur bonne journée bonne
journée bonne journée merci
[Musique]